speedrun time here we go thanks again
guys everybody
remains um i appreciate it hopefully
this isn't too much for people still
still different thing with the tier one
let's go so we got um a karo khan here
[Music]
now we have a karaoke on here um
we have a karo khan here yes
c6 is a bad faith i'm blocking the
knights development okay so we have our
first advanced car oh guys
we have our first advanced car and and
simon
yeah thanks again for the 8 000 bits
you're the man appreciate it
okay um now what's the main move here
what's the main move here we can all
agree that the car count is all pawns
and no talk
so i play c5 in my blitz games but
that's not what we're going to play here
f4 so the reason the karakan exists is
because
we get a chance to develop the bishop
outside of the pawn chain
and that's exactly what we have done so
he goes f4 that is not a very good move
and he's trying to grab more of the
center but in doing so he's
curbing the development of the bishop
and he's weakening his king
and the proper continuation here is to
play e6
so after the game this is our first
advanced caro
and i'll explain the sort of like why do
we even do any of this what is the
rationale behind this
and one of the rationales is that we get
a closed
center and the first thing to understand
about the close center i'll expand on
this more after the game
thank you mick love another five thank
you so much first thing to understand
about the closed center is that
often times it consists of pawn chains
and we see a pawn chain here we see a
pawn chain here right
blue is speaking of blue and red
pawns are finding each other um blue
pawns
are a black pawn chain and d4 e5 is
white's pawn chain
and the side that has more levers and
more ability
to attack and undermine the other side's
pawn chain
is the side that holds a very big
initiative and
the rationale behind the karaoke is that
black is the side
that holds more of an ability to attack
white's pawn chain
on the other side white has more space
and those two things are often
what counter balance each other but
first of all we don't want to
yield this prime parking spot so easily
right
we want to trade on our own terms we
want to trade on our own terms what does
that mean
it means that this bishop should be
replaced by a knight
and a very typical move here is knight
h6 okay
knight h6 and if he takes on f5 we take
with the knight why do we want a knight
on f5
in order for the knight to pressure d4
speaking of pressuring d4
how do we continue doing that i'm going
to have to play a little bit faster
how do we continue pressuring d4
see yeah c5 very good guys attacking the
base of the bond chain
okay
c5 is right
so we also open up the c6 square for the
night
right um and i
i remind you guys with a speed run if
you have specific questions i'll answer
them after the game we still do the post
game analysis
and then i take your specific questions
here i'm trying to give a more broad
view
of what i'm trying to accomplish okay
takes on f5 we take with the knight
see how now we have two attackers on the
d4 pawn
now you might say well big deal what's
the big deal he can just take on c5 and
that's something we'll talk about as
well
castles now we can take on d4
but if you want to play this clinically
um it makes sense to hold off on it for
just one more second and play
and play knight c6 or queen b6 is
possible but let's hold that
thought in case he plays c3 then we'll
play queen b6 because why because knight
c6
is more flexible what i mean by that is
we know we want to play this move anyway
right
we want to play this move regardless
um and and
okay so c3 and now that he has shown his
desire to
further defend that pawn well actually
here's the funny thing we can take first
and then play queen b6 and that way we
win the pawn
but i'm going to show you guys something
really cool let's go queen b6
i'll talk about that after the game i'm
noting that down
so in a game that i would play i would
take first
but i'm playing music with the hopes
that he takes because i'm going to show
you guys a really cool idea
and i know min knows that i'm thinking
that's right
okay b3 unfortunately he's not going to
let us show it he's just going to give
us the pawn
and we take it
there's a lot to talk about here in the
advanced so this is a good game
yeah um now cd right we've won a pawn
we've won a pawn and not only one upon
it's a very important pawn
it breaks up his pawn chain his entire
position starts to
crumble here knight c takes d4
and now we enter sort of already the
decisive stage we've won a pawn we have
a
we have a protected passer on d5
and rogue force fantastic question which
i'll tackle after the game sorry to keep
answering
that way we'll i'll uh circle back to it
as it's fashionable to say these days
um and i will actually circle back to it
okay so castle's
castle is a circle
all right so now
he goes king h1 so he yeah that is a
good move by white he gets
out of the immediate threat of a
discovery
and there's nothing that we should do
here other than to
think logically well what have we done
yet what haven't we done yet in this
position what can we do
yeah so bishop c5 is a great move
and h5 would have also been good but
let's save them i don't think he's going
to go g4 which probably would have been
the correct move
all right
okay what do we take with
and that's a mistake he collapses
thank you uh work ends for the tier one
bishop is right
yeah bishop is right boom the rook is
not operating in good faith
okay yeah so
this is good this is good stuff
and that is a bad that is one bad faith
guys
i think we can all agree that blackjack
thanks for the prime appreciate it
the rook is red right now blue right now
just colors
okay the game is over basically he loses
his rook he loses his rook
and
what kind that's weird
yeah he loses the okay g4 he does find
g4 okay
now one mistake that i often see players
make right
is well tunnel vision you could
specifically in the context of automatic
moves
automatic modes when you play move like
bishop d4
a lot of people will automatically grab
the rook on a1 but
see the bigger picture here for a second
see the bigger picture here for a second
um if you take on a1 you give up the
knight and
white at least gets in exchange for the
rook and that's a significant amount of
material so do we need to take the rook
immediately
not knight e3 now if we play knight e3 i
know that's tempting
but he simply takes the knight folks and
then that very same bishop which we've
assigned
the vital task of winning the rook is
now going to be distracted and taking
the bishop
not knight g3 we don't need to do
anything we just need to drop the knife
back
the point here isn't to activate the
knight we are
seeking far greener pastures and a lot
of people are asking what about knights
either yes knight c3
uh curbs his losses that's what he
should play and he loses
only his knife but then he loses his
knife that's huge
um that's that's already huge
all right
so
what fools we were is in your face
you know what else percentage oh man i
already i forfeited my opportunity to do
that
simon because i was gonna say you know
what else was
censored
your face all right so you see how i
treat people who
um cheer to my channel a fool's mate oh
god well that yep that would hurt
people's feelings who miss queen takes
f2
all right um so
but do you guys see what i'm saying here
um we simply drop the knight back
and and we win the rook and i think part
of this comes from an illusion and he
goes knight c3 kudos to my opponent he's
finding a lot of good moves
all right how should we do now well what
should we do now well
one way to think about it is his king is
very weak his king is very weak
um and what is that what does that mean
well
he's played the move g4 that's opened up
a direct avenue to his king
how do we exploit that avenue well we
can put a queen on c6
um right and that potentially sets up a
discover check
we have a lot of things we can do we can
castle but there's no rush
in castling let's go d4 because that
does a couple of things it secures the
bishop
on c3 good it advances the password good
prepares queen c6 is good and if you
look at this knight on e7 on the
somewhere in the number four number five
of our agenda
is perhaps to reactivate the knight it's
not doing all that much on e7
and what pathway does the move d4
potentially create
and you shouldn't overthink this like
this is the absolute best move it's
probably not even the best move
yeah knight d5 and then potentially even
to e3 but what i wanted to say
is that there is a bit of an illusion
among some people
that and and this comes from a good
place but like every single move
has to be active no retreating moves and
that's why in this position
even if somebody understands the concept
of just moving the knight they still
want to find an active square and
you have to have your i'm sorry to
belabor this but you have to have your
priorities in order if you know that
you're winning the rook
the relative position of the night is
not going to matter
it's going to matter far more that the
night is safe then that the knight is
nominally more active
all right that's just what i wanted to
say
okay this should be two and as we
discussed let's slide the queen over to
c6
and after king ge1 again first thing we
need to ask ourselves do we need to take
on b2
the answer is clearly not an answer for
you that's why we put upon t4 what
should we do after he moves his king
look at you look at you same if he
doesn't matter look at you
95 93 there we go now
why aren't we castling some people say
uh because we don't need to
uh the king is perfectly safe it's
it's it's all alone king ju1 is a good
move
and now we can go 93 we don't have to
rush that though i think that now may be
a good time to castle
how do we know that we don't need to
well it's it's simple look at the
position with your own eyes
and and i i'm not seeing anything you
you're not seeing um
he doesn't have what pieces is he going
to attack the king always
consider the worst case scenario if you
gave him like five moves could he even
possibly
generate any threats against the king
and you'll see that the answer is no
so let's castle or play rook c8 now
we're just gonna castle
not because the king is in any danger
but just
you know just to potentially bring the
rook into the game and connect the rugs
more out of that consideration
and don't overthink this everything wins
here it's not that important to find
the move it's um
it's not about that here it's about
making a series of reasonable moves
all right just wanted to make that very
clear
yeah this is a really good game because
he's defending super well
he's reporting okay queen d3 no he's
gonna he's gonna make a move now
when you've got a situation like this i
call this a standoff
standoffs are tactically i was gonna say
politically charged
all right well they're all politically
charged are tactically charged on the
chessboard
situations and you know when you have a
possibility of capturing something you
need to spend at least a couple of
seconds on every move considering
if you've even if you've decided not to
take you need to spend a couple of
seconds per move considering what
happens if you do
is a capture by its very definition
changes the position in some significant
win so that could open up the
possibility
for tactics here a fork on c1 which you
would see if you considered bishop takes
b2 right
this is not a matter of queen c1 being
hard to see it's a matter of
allowing yourself to consider the trade
that's
just a small piece of advice there now
the game is over
okay um let's have a look because i'm
excited
to introduce you guys to the intricacies
here new game
bishop f5 all right so this is the
advanced karo khan bishop f5 develops
the car con
outside the pawn chain now to understand
and i explain this
um i think reasonably well with the pawn
chain
analogy but let's abstract this entirely
and just consider
how the pawn structure works here in the
french and the caribbean because the
french and the karakon are very similar
openings
when you think about them to do that
we're going to employ chess base and i'm
sorry for the
if i'm ranting here i'm excited i mean
you know i like these uh
these explanations because i feel like
they can help you understand how to play
in closed positions too
so we just have the pawns here we don't
have any pieces right forget the pieces
both the karakan and the french involve
allowing white to control the center
think a desert pago and we got a hype
train at 5 40.
all right that's fact one and that's
already why
these openings weren't popular when
chess began
because when chess began you know people
understood that you want to control the
center with pawns and so why would you
voluntarily allow
uh white to control the center with his
two pawns
then people came along and said okay in
the karo kind of the french black
controls a part of the center okay in
the french
black is a pawn on d5 and it's only that
he has a pawn on e6
and most of the time if white plays the
advanced french white plays e5 right
now the karo khan this pawn is here and
this pawn is here right
but the difference structurally is
minimal
almost non-existent in fact they can
morph into each other
because in the karo khan you often play
e6 and then c5
and in the french you often play c5 and
one for one fell swoop
all right and as i explained
the rationale behind these two openings
is one in the same
you lure white into creating a pawn
chain
and you've got the weapons to attack the
spawn chain from both sides
um a with the pawn on c5 attacking the
base of the punch
and b playing the move f6 which you'll
often see in the french attack in the
foot of the pawn chain
and that in turn creates peace mobility
when you break down your opponent's
control of the center
it not only is inherently good because
then you control more of the center
but it also often gives your pieces more
mobility
now the main difference between the
karaoke and the french we need to
understand it we need to add
black's dark squared bishop all right
now in the french you have the very
famous problem
of the french bishop whether or not
white plays e5 the positive side in 500
bits from frank is the
tomtom thing for the sub geez positive
aside is that white goes c5 and one fell
swoop and in the karo khan
um the situation is flipped you get your
bishop outside of the pawn chain
awesome but on the other hand you spent
two tempe to go c5
right and and that's that might not seem
significant but it really is that's a
pretty significant trade-off all right
so that's um kind of a way to
structurally understand the character
now what's the downside of all this is
black just better because he gets a
chance to do all of this
no because white gets a huge space
advantage in both openings
or light square bishop this pawn on e5
is a is a big deal it's controlling the
f6 square
which makes it hard to develop the
knight all right
you so you are taking on a bunch of
these challenges
um when you're playing particularly the
karo khan and
a lot of these challenges center around
how to develop these two pieces
because they're struggling for resources
the knight doesn't have f6
so either it has to go out onto the rim
as we did or you have to do something
like this but then where do you put the
bishop
so it often takes a long time to get
your king side out
but if you do all of that and if you
manage to pressure white center white's
position often collapses in a
spectacular way
all right so that's a little structural
explanation i hope that makes sense
let's go into the game itself no no no
no advancing is the main move and i'm
not trying to suggest that advancing in
either the fence or the car
is bad in the karo kind of the advanced
variation is like
basically the most popular line nowadays
at the top level
um in the french it's one of the most
popular it's by no means is it bad
but both require precision from white so
if you're a relative beginner
i don't recommend actually um
playing the conventional advance in
either the cairo con or the french
unless you're willing to study it
carefully which then would make it fine
um but there are alternatives you can
play the open car okay you can just play
knight c3 same with the french
all right this is much easier to play
because the center is open
but what i really recommend for people
who are beginners if you want to line
against the kyrokan
i recommend the exchange with bishop d3
because this clarify this is a
compromise the position is not entirely
open you know black still is a pawn
you still have this little traffic jam
there's a little bit of pawn structure
imbalance white has three on two here
and black has four on three on the other
side
and white is very simple development so
i feel like this is a good compromise
that's what i think now after e5 let's
flip the board bishop f5
let's continue nope c4 is good okay so
f4 is already
not a big mistake but it's a little bit
overcommittal as i explained
and you want to you want to time your
questions to where we are
in the game so ask any questions but
please time them to where i am
now white is a bunch of systems here
right and we'll face
all of them if there's knight c3 there's
there's things as aggressive as g4
there's h4
you can go after on all of these moves
try to go after this bishop immediately
and literally like h4 tries to trap the
bishop right
that's the bottom line or white can
emphasize
development knight f3 bishop e2 called
the short variation
that's i would say considered the main
line um and all of those have their own
theoretical
um continuations he goes f4 we go e6
if he tries g4 here he falls under this
check
he goes bishop d3 now knight h6 i hope
this move makes sense to everybody we
are trading on our own terms
again one of the biggest problems that
black has to solve in the karakan are
these two pieces
and if we can find a home for them then
we're
well on the way to reaching a good
position
all right why not h6 and not 97 well 97
just blocks this bishop that's the only
thing
the downside to this move is that the
knight is on the rim but i am already
anticipating that the knight has passage
to f5 frankfurt airport guys
the frankfurt airport analogy right
you're flying to paris paris is on f5
nothing can stop us from reaching paris
all right it is a move after f4
it is but i want it to hold out until he
goes bishop d3
so now we go c5 executing the main idea
of the karo khan
well nick lovin then we can trade
ourselves and go knight f5 all right
um no without f4 sometimes you do play
knight h6 yes
um yes knight h6 is a move i can show
you guys from games from my career where
uh strong gm's i mean i i can right off
the top of my head
i can show you guys a game against the
carbocon expert peruvian grandmaster
granda zuniga that i played when i was
in i am
and if you guys just want to see how
this all works
and what makes the karo khan so mind
mind-bogglingly complex
here you go by all means
here it is here's an example of black
here i have a karaka now i played in a
very interesting sentence
i want to see if you guys can tell me
this is a common system
what the point of getting the knight to
b3 is with your newfound knowledge of
the karo khan
what is white's point here why spend two
moves doing this crap
very nice
discourage c5 exactly discourage c5
and you can see that my opponent goes
knight h6 as early as move six
and he's not afraid of bishop takes h6
and the reason why this is very
complicated stuff right it's hard to
explain this all verbally
there is concrete properties here but
you open the g
for the bottom line is that black can
actually castle long
and use the g file to his advantage in
addition
the absence of the dark squared bishop
is going to make it much harder for
white to stop c5 right
um and and if you preserve the bishop
then you can
easily more easily deal with c5 so
you can see why does he put a knight in
it to give the bishop the square on e7
and now he's developed all of his pieces
and the knight goes to f5
so you guys can see like the same types
of moves are made
and that's why if you learn the karakan
really well it can be an incredibly good
opening to play
because by and large the ideas remain
the same across most lines
and you can have a very very fun time
just consistently
killing people with those ideas okay
um you you still want to play c5 for
castle long sometimes yeah
okay so take stakes knight castles
knight c6
now we're just putting pressure on this
pawn and
okay if white now very important
if white plays c3 you do not want to
play c4 here
you don't want to play c4 why not well
because this closes down the center even
further
and i know what you want to do you want
to go b5 b4 but even after you do that
it's going to be very hard to break down
this pawn right how do i know that well
i'm applying
and i introduce this to my students as
the best case scenario tesla
there's the best case scenario test and
the worst case scenario test best case
scenario test
let's say my opponent you have a plan
trying to evaluate the merits of that
plan
what you want to do is say well let's
say my opponent gives me
as many moves as possible to execute
this plan what happens afterward is it
as good as i thought it was b5
so let's do that let's say white castles
and make some inoffensive moves
you get everything you wanted are we
really
going to win this pawn anytime soon
right no this is a pyrrhic victory it
looks good
this is not a serious minority attack
and
you wouldn't connect for that is true
and so c4 do you
do you play this ever absolutely there
are situations when you want to do
something
like this generally those situations
involve having
far greater um beef on the
side of the board where you're
conducting this attack here
we already are attacking the d4 pawn and
we have two attackers on it there's no
there's no point
in closing down his counter productive
you would just want to go knight c6
and then queen b6 much as we did in the
game oh so he went c6 he won c3
okay sorry for the rent now what happens
if dc
now this position um is a really
interesting one because we've already
gotten all of our pieces out
but black also has a very very pretty
tactical concept
and you should already notice that the
king is out of squares any situation
where the king is out of squares you
should start thinking about tactics
what am i talking about here this is
almost winning for black
yeah boom boom boom
all right this is as old as the hills
the h file opens
this is covered this is checkmate all
right so
move h5 is um
virtually correct i mean white can
defend against this but it's like
very very hard to all right so
remember this idea h5h4 that's why when
you get a little bit past beginner level
um
you have to learn that in some such you
have to understand and even if you are a
beginner you can understand this
even though you shouldn't emphasize this
then in many situations
you want to keep your king in the center
because that affords you opportunities
that otherwise you wouldn't have
well knight c3 and 92 is the only
defense i think because if white plays
h3
then that weakens the g3 square and that
wins the exchange
so this idea of the king being
boxed in on the corner and the rook
delivery made from h8
is universal across a lot of openings in
a lot of different positions by the way
and um this is one of those things where
a soviet coaches in the old day
particularly varetsky
they what they recommended was keeping a
notebook of what they called
notebook of position of tactical ideas
in tactical patterns where you would
assemble and
literally cut diagrams out of books and
stuff
um and nobody's gonna do this now but
every time you saw a cool tactical
pattern such as this one you would
um you know you would print print it out
or whatever and you would paste it into
your physical notebook like this one
and and you would label them and every
once in a while you would review all of
these patterns
and that greatly enriches um
your tactical knowledge thank you
captain comic and
let's say that you had done this with
but but let me show you the merits of
that let's say that you had done this
with this idea
and then you come across uh and then you
you're facing uh your name is mark
taymano
your name is mark tamanov you're facing
anatoly karpov
um who in 1977 is essentially one of the
top players in the world
and you're playing the black pieces you
don't have very high hopes for winning
but you find yourself in a pretty
interesting position and you find
yourself
imagine that you are mark taimanov
grand master solid grand master but
nowhere near the top of top of the top
so
it's black to play do you notice any
similarities
between this and what i just showed you
guys
do you notice any similarities
all right entertainment of channeled
here we go yes well the queen is
in the role of the bishop it's blocking
the king's axis you don't have an h pawn
but that can actually be a good thing so
you need to tell yourself wait a second
if there was no h2 pawn in my rook
landed on the h file
that would be checkmate all right
so now that seems like a pipe dream
because the rook is nowhere near the h
file
but if you've been doing your exercises
then you should start thinking of ways
to try to make that happen right
how can we make that happen well we
should notice that white's queen
is tasked with defending the rogue there
is a standoff between the rooks
and so the queen is overloaded that
means the queen's defense of g3
of this square isn't actual you can play
knight g3 track and karpov resigned
if he takes with a queen then rook takes
b1 and if he takes with a pawn
and this is a beautiful move rook a8
and you cannot stop rook h8
checkmate you can give up your queen on
e3 otherwise it's completely unstoppable
so this is a a combination that's shown
to
every russian schoolboy it's very pretty
and i'm not just i'm not going to claim
that you automatically see this if
you're aware of the pattern
but you're a lot more likely to if you
put your mind to it knight g3 check
first you can't take with the queen
because you lose
and there's no way to stop rick h8 you
can convince yourself of this just look
at every legal move in the position
there's no way
um and i know it was easy right after i
showed you the example this is not an
easy position
to understand and i just wanted to
hopefully this enriches your knowledge a
little bit
rook b4 is still rook h8 that's
checkmate back to the speed
okay so that's what i wanted to show you
guys after queen b6
the same thing would have happened in
this position we would have gone h5
h4 and knight g3 and um
he went b3 which which exacerbates the
situation
and um yes he takes knight takes d4
bishop c5 just developing is great and
bishop takes d4
wins the wins the rook and 97 is the
best move
um what's his best move there you know i
it might actually be uh d takes c5
and and if we go h5 in this position
well the computer
always finds some way to defend against
this kind of stuff it says queen e2
and then knight g5 not an easy move to
see him white is still much worse
that is not an easy move to see the idea
is after knight g3
you have this knight h3 move to block
the check right and block the checkmate
but white is hanging by a single thread
here and black's still got a great
position we can even castle long
oh we've blundered the pawn but wait a
second what was the night doing that g5
again odd it was covering the h3 square
so now this is made
that's that's not an easy that's an easy
find so
at this point this position just
collapses all right
so bishop c5 well if you play f6 there
if you play f6 there then white can take
on f6 you got to be careful about those
kinds of moves and always try to detect
the danger
okay so
that's the game yeah it takes bishop c5
and the only other important moment 97
patiently retreating the night and
preserving it
so when do we castle long in the car oh
um well there's a couple of
circumstances usually you castle short
certainly in most positions you castle
short
but i can't answer that question too
generally
now there are situations where as i
explained to you guys before you put a
knight on h6 and white ends up taking it
and you castle long because you want to
keep the g file open for the rook i can
show you examples of that
um and another scenario is yeah for
whatever reason you want to attack on
the king's side and you judge the risk
isn't as
as wide but it's it's definitely less
prevalent than cast linking side